NBC is free cable isn't it it's free TV  anybody has access to it sure sure  Fox News free cable it's not you have to  pay for it right you have to pay for  cable to watch Greg Gutfeld so let me  get this straight the one with the free  audience is losing the one that has you  have to pay to watch it 100 by 2x that  by the way that is absolutely  embarrassing to think about and it can  build from a successful producer the  most successful producer right now in  all of the universe of cable and  television is Greg Gutfeld he created  the five he owns a big chunk of that  show he's the most successful in the  biggest viewership he's King right now